voilà bon allez dans lé pa amb ou des
noms c'est une très belle femme oui
c'est une très belle femme mais je
n'avais pas envie que je vienne au bout
l assemblée
alors il y avait alors un bon jour sa
fin tout le monde en la parole c'est pas
moi je suis comme marlène schiappa je ne
regarde pas ce qui se dit sur moi de sur
les rayons des réseaux sociaux car vous
êtes vous pouvez m'insulter ça m'est
égal je le lis pas donc c'est pas grave
alors à damas quand je jouais bien
m'expliquer alors allez-y c'est alors
d'abord
effectivement raciale quéquette une
femme très estimable et le principal
reproche que je lui faisais c'était
plutôt sur une autre déclaration c'était
pas du tout il se trouve que dans toutes
ces photos je l'avais vu en boubou ce
qu'il me pose aucun problème j'ai rien
contre les boubous le vôtre est très
jolie on a déjà parlé à d'accord et
simplement l'assemblée nationale n'est
pas pour moi un endroit où on doit être
le porte parole de ses origines de sa
propre culture et laurier exactement la
même chose si un juif orthodoxe arrivait
à l'assemblée nationale avec soul
streible vous savez le grand show ou
bretonnes en coiffe bigoudène et à
l'assemblée nationale je veux dire on
est les représentants du peuple français
on n'est pas là pour être le porte
parole ou pour même pour ramener disons
ses origines c'est tout ce que je
voulais dire j'ai un parcours en
revanche si vous me permettez régie
j'avais été plutôt choquée par une de
ces deux déclarations qui ont plus à mon
avis est fausse c'est quand elle a dit
j'ai leur niveau scolaire de cm2 d'abord
je ne pense pas que ce soit bresse le
peu que j'ai lu ou vu d'elle elle m'a
l'air plutôt d'être une femme mieux
formés que cela mais je trouve que oui
pour faire la loi il faut des
compétences et je sais tout le monde va
me dire que des surdiplômés n'ont pas
très bien réussi mais c'est pas une
raison si vous voulez pour considérer
que l'absence de diplôme est en soi un
mérite donc d'abord je ne le crois pas
qu'elle a un niveau scolaire de cm2 je
ne pense pas du tout et ça c est ça
c'est une déclaration qui m'a beaucoup
ce qu'ils voient l'avenir sa première à
damas est cet axe et à déranger c'est ça
on va pas déranger ça m'attriste ça m'a
prise d'avoir aujourd'hui à répondre à
un discours sera la tenue vestimentaire
je pense quand même en france nos
anciens noyau assez lutté notamment
16ème siècle avec les guerres d'euros
des gens avec l'édit de nantes
exactement en 1598 caf apporte connaître
notre histoire et chaque match et n'a
pas quand je fais des cours historiques
mais c'est important le monde au nez
lors qu'on s'exprime on parle avec
instruction et meilleur qu'aujourd'hui
une femme journaliste tu as quand même
l'habitude de tout ce qui est liberté
bien présent puisque david n'est pas
vraiment allez me dire qu'aujourd'hui on
essaie de résoudre une personne un tony
vestimentaire on lui prête ses
intentions dire qu'à venir est une
victime en terre à l'assemblée nationale
avant de présenter sa culture
intellectuellement parlant c'est très
faible alors que très très faible
surtout par rapport à ce qu'elle dit par
rapport aux études mois jusqu'à preuve
contraire ce qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
à des personnes qui sont condamnées des
multiples reprises et peuvent encore
représenté 5 sata français quant à eux à
titre personnel je ne me représente pas
et dire qu'aujourd'hui une personne
parce qu'elle a pu dire que allah un
niveau de 5 2 c'était un message fort
pour dire que aujourd'hui en france
heureusement notre pays et restons cela
reste la mention l'ascension sociale le
développement social et surtout l'accès
à pouvoir être un jour représentant de
la nation française vit à la députation
est accessible à tous et nous rachel
kéké dans mon quartier de nos cités
aussi dans les villages mais hussein un
parent d un bonus elle a donné à la
donne et elle a donné à donner ce que la
france méritait maman j'ai dit à mon ami
m alors on se coupe pas la parole oui
mais désormais il faudrait en finir
comme sur le baume au coeur on peut me
dire que si vous avez du bon mot qui m'a
mis du baume au coeur c'est sa
déclaration d'amour à la france d'accord
c'est une patrie vous avez
donc tout simplement dans belle baie
d'hyères là le reproche que maintenant
c'est le pro tour en tentant de rfi et
que je pense que nous aurons tous les
ans et que je pense car ils sont
repartis communautariste et qui joue sur
le communautarisme j'avais peur et vous
pouvez me dire que c'était un procès
d'intention et je me suis trompé tombe
dans le berkshire
vous écoutez ou pas non sérieux on
essaye de bon alors vous avez peur
qu'elle se présente comme le porte
parole d'une communauté nature je ne me
mets pas la gauche jamais je n'ai pas
tendance est donc de la communauté noire
ou d'une communauté mais je vous dis que
ce sera la même chose avec une bretonne
avec un juif orthodoxe avec n'importe
qui à l'assemblée un député il
représente même pas sa circonscription
il représente le peuple français le
monde alors qu'est de la diversité
sociale c'est très très bien mais je
reviens sur cette histoire de niveau
scolaire parce que ça j'ai trouvé ça
s'ils voulaient d'abord encore une fois
je ne pense pas qu'elle ait le niveau
scolaire de cm2 sinon elle s'exprimerait
pas comme elle le fait parce que
franchement même au bac si vous volez on
voit ce que
ça ne crois pas que ce soit on parle de
niveau national ne doit pas que ce soit
vrai mais c'est près de cette charge
je suis navré sa demande de couper ton
blog soluble et je n'aime pas l'anti
intellectualisme qui sévit dans notre
pays c'est à dire je n'aime pas cette
idée que parce que des gens diplômés ont
failli deviens le fait de ne pas avoir
de diplôme serait en dessous j'aimerais
avoir l'avis de tous est favori car
gilles aulas mettez vos pancartes s'il
vous plaît parce que l'on sait pas ce
que vous allez dire donc vous avez des
pancartes america question vous avez pas
je la connais pas là est ce que vous
êtes allé trop loin oui voilà il y en a
d'autres où l'on rêve pour moi vous êtes
allé beaucoup trop loin les gens ça m'a
choqué tellement aimé ça m'a choqué et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi là vous
théorisé votre discours vous le policer
ça aurait été pareil si c'était une
bretonne mais quand on regarde
l'émission direct ça sort spontanément
c'est sur le boubou c'est à dire que là
on voit offrir une fois de bigoudène non
là on voit que spontanément vous
exprimer ce que vous ressentez et ma
chaire elisabeth lévy c'est doublement
raciste c'est raciste parce qu'elle est
noire et parce qu'elle peut porter un
boubou il ya un mépris une
condescendance et c'est raciste parce
que vous l'attaquez sur le costume mais
c'est sa fierté porter le costume c'est
sa fierté c'est culturel c'est joli
regard des portes et un boubou c'est
bien on peut représenter la france au
rebond attendu quand même j'ai parlé
assemblée nationale et bas à l'assemblée
nationale il ya plus l'obligation de
cravate on peut arriver habillés comme
on veut moi je n'aimerais pas été
baptisé le boubou donc vous êtes
doublement
racing n'est pas d'accord dans cette
phrase morts et choqué si elle avait été
gratuite et si elle avait parlé de
boubous juste uniquement parce que c'est
une femme noire là ce qui me choque pas
c'est qu'elle l'a vu visiblement
plusieurs fois à mais j'ai tenu et
qu'elle craignait peut-être qu'elle
porte une tenue qu'elle estime
inapproprié
comme sur pourraient être inappropriées
de porter une casquette ou devenir en
maillot est ce que ça vous aurait
dérangé qu'elle porte le bon choix voilà
que quelqu'un voilà voilà dix ans que
lorsque vous en tenue de com vous avez
dit ont tenu
debout à l'assemblée à sion est ce que
ça vous choque
ici qui savent pas du tout personne
pourtant que ça représente l'ensemble
des français mais après ça vous plaît ça
me choque pourrait trouver sa
inappropriée
inappropriée c'est pas l'endroit d'avoir
des revendications communautaires on
représente les français maintenant gérer
vu aussi je ne connais rien de sade
damas parce que ce qu'on a dit qu'elle
était femme de ménage je trouve
formidable que quelqu'un est pas parenti
élitisme formidable que quelqu'un de
connecté à la réalité en fait aux
difficultés du quotidien puisse débattre
avec d'autres députés je trouve ça
formidable avec un mélange social et en
plus c'est vrai et déjà été j'avais été
aussi touché par son discours ce que
vous avez à l'éthique où elle a remercié
la france pour dire au sujet alors je
peux les iran mais partie du jeu merci à
la france donc vrai que du coup le
préjugé du boubou peut-être que c'était
d'arriver à l'assemblée dans un
magnifique tailleur pantalon
non mais
oui mais pardon et foires être faut il
faut arrêter quelque chose effectivement
là ce qui me choque moi elle sera arrivé
à la semaine nationale en boubou vous
auriez pu dire je suis choqué que là
elle est pas en boubou et vous dis là
encore les pendent au bout là
véritablement vous ne pouvez pas cacher
que cette phrase est totalement raciste
elle montre et tout allait vraiment
vraiment votre collation des contenus
quelques mais non mais non mais non les
âmes est elle elle n'est pas en vue
heureusement déjà les ports boubou ça
prouve déjà que vous juger quelqu'un
qu'il est mais qui n'est pas l'aspect
national en bout
ce qu'elle n'a pas fait pour vraiment
votre votre génie à votre des otages
vous pensez c'est du racisme et l'amour
les célèbres les soins donnés ce nabot
réponse aux batailles célèbres
maintenant laissez-moi répondre à ces
accusations de racisme en fait ne me
touche plus parce que dès qu'on dit
quelque chose à un prix modique et le
problème et ça vous ennuie pages de
rieumes à prades donc dès qu'on dit
quelque chose qui n'est réglé bon
d'accord j'arrête vous faisons vous avez
envie de parler bout maintenant elle
avait laissé la finale et celle à venir
mathieu aux cheveux roux va le finir
plus pour parler je le veux achaque fois
qu'on dit quelque chose si vous voulez
qu'ils s'éloignent de votre grande
opinion s'est rassis c'est l'accusation
qui d'ailleurs je vous signale qu'elle
ne le fait plus de mal à personne parce
que vous l'employez tout le temps c'est
à dire que vous vous traitez de raciste
toute personne qui critiqueraient par la
porte du propos mois dans comme en haut
de votre chaîne non non tu devrais dire
excusez moi celle l'accusation de
racisme mais je vais vous répondre sur
un point vous me dites moi ça me
dérangerait pas qu'elle a et à
l'assemblée nationale au move ou non
vous la france le tournis mais nous une
part j'ai le royal dérange d'abord je ne
crois pas que le règlement de
l'assemblée le permettent mais bon ça
j'ai pas vérifié mais revient de nom
deuxièmement je suis moi favorable à
l'assimilation quand tu vas à
l'assemblée nationale tu représentes le
peuple français c'est une gestion saine
et zabeth lé paris vers la
subventionnant vous me mettez du camp
vous la voyez heureusement des gens et
les allusions à bouillir toute les celts
sûr j'avais vu d'elle il se trouve
d'accord que je l' ai vu à billets comme
ici au lof une et encore une fois ça ne
me dérangera pour qu'elle soit juste
voulez vous répondre pardon j'oubliais
votre prénom mais la fois femme de
ménage ça et qu'elle est menée ces
combats d'ailleurs absolument vraiment
des bons combats et même qu'elle ait été
le pénis dans le passé je m'en fiche
mais alors complètement c'est à dire que
c'est ce qui est sorti aussi qu'elle ait
soutenu marine le pen dans le passé
raymond robbe de liberté ces souris
quand l'apparition du qu'en dira-t-on à
ce sujet donc c'est vraiment super
malade
la division offshore divers sujets
de débat delphine
pour une fois je bois les paroles de
mathieu et je leur ligne exactement sur
ses ondes différent
de lui donner les dates de mykonos à
celle du 10 au 21 c'est vrai que on peut
dire s'il était en boubou vous regardez
et vous dites moi je trouve que c'est
pas la tenue appropriée et ça s'entend
mais là elle était pas et donc
directement vous vous la sélection en
disant adhérer au mouvement enfin mais
on est dans un monde de susceptibilité
de [ __ ]
sur des photos d'elle que j'ai vu oui
encore elle l'était et alors je constate
qu'elle ne l'est pas et je vais vous en
réjouissez vous en réjouissez je
m'engage c'est ça qui est terrible alors
est ce inquiétant mais pas raciste moi
je suis pour les mêmes ceintures ainsi
donc en voudriez pas par exemple qu'un
député arrive en djellaba par exemple ah
non la meilleure est tellement pas parce
qu'après tout si je ne voudrais pas
donc quand les l'assemblée nationale
doit doit être des sanctuaires si vous
êtes dans la rue et des avait déjà
beaucoup donné quoi
l'école et l'assemblée ce sont des sons
galère c'était avec sa lumière que en
fait vous arrivez dans une situation
intérieure de sa de ses origines suis je
vous ai donné l'exemple d'un juif
orthodoxe qui arriverait avec son grand
chapeau mais la réponse est là vous
répondez en rose un second but vous
croyez-vous meyrin il a raison vous
répondez dans un second rôle ah non mais
c est ce que vous comprenez malgré tout
que votre votre sailly et provoqué ce
que ça a provoqué non alors de voyeur se
passe car en fait vous anticipez quelque
chose soit
des balles et cela alors d'abord c'est
une extrapolation retail pas seulement
une anticipation puisque je vous le
répète visiblement vous n'avez pas
entendu toutes les photos que j'avais vu
d'elle et ça ne le dérange nous manque
quand elle mène son combat syndical elle
peut s'habiller comme elle veut d'accord
donc est effectivement là où on peut me
reprocher un procès d'intention mais
c'est à cause de ces affiliations
politiques en réalité c'est
qu'effectivement je n'aime pas le
communautarisme mais je constate
d'ailleurs qu'elle ne l'a pas été dans
ses propos comment il a été simplement
comme je l'avais toujours vu en boubou
j'ai été agréablement surprise de la
voir dans cette tenue et oui je pense
que ça n'est pas bien d'arriver ni à
l'école ni à l'assemblée nationale avec
lui
connu qui a tant mieux s'il vous plaît
rigoler vous avez faire verser dans son
commerce est contemporain c'est quand
même une très grande chose mais moi je
vais vous dire un truc c'est que ce que
je constate
c'est qu'en fait vous cherchez les
racistes mais non on va parler
trop vite on l'accusé était alors à
damas qu'on apprenne n'a pas évolué
depuis longtemps déjà vous répondre sur
le racisme contre lequel quelqu'un alors
vers 21h15 et racisme j'ai choisi
cristaux
mais par rapport à la représentation
faut comprendre
la représentation faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui nous donnons kg donne
aussitôt un réel manque de
représentation de la chose politique ou
voilà on essaie de faire en sorte que
beaucoup de personnes par an port on
sait comment plus mobilisés dans le
quartier puissent accéder soit à
l'échelle municipal départemental et
régional soit nationale et le fait
d'avoir une personne qu'on achète kevin
madone vouliez clairement où amour
présent mais moi mon voyage ne sont pas
alors je pense que vous faites une
confusion sur ce qu'est la
représentation moi par exemple je ne me
sens pas spécialement représentée par
quelqu'un qui me ressemble par exemple
je me sens beaucoup moins bien
représenterez par sandrine rousseau que
par n'importe quel homme pas trop
déconstruit comme et n'ai pas besoin de
quelqu'un de mots si on veut la porte
aux deux tibias les honneurs à mon
métier non mais c'est vrai même pas donc
je ne crois pas moi on a besoin de vous
ressemble en revanche je comprends quand
on dit que socialement on a besoin de
gens qui est des expériences très
diverses